네. 안녕하세요. 빌사남의 노크
김요수입니다. 최근에 악구정 현대가
93억에 낙찰이 됐어요. 왜 경매로
이렇게 낙찰를 받는지 제가 오늘 좀
설명을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
빌사남의 노크.
우선 경매로 낙찰하는 이유 중에 가장
큰게 토지 거래 허가 때문이에요.
어, 최근에 토지 거래 허가가
묶기면서 강남구라든지 서초구라든지
용산구의 아파트를 매입할 때 토지
거래 허가를 받습니다. 근데 경매로
낙찰받는 경우에는 토지 거래 허가를
받지 않아도 돼요. 그리고 실거주
의무가 필요한데 아무래도이 토지 거래
허가를 받지 않다 보니까 경매로 낙찰
받을 경우에는 직접 거 안 해도
됩니다. 바로 전세를 줘도 돼요.
네. 그래서 이런 이점 때문에 경매로
낙찰를 받는 경우가 많아졌어요.
그리고 무엇보다 자금 조달 계획서도
안 써도 돼요. 규제 지역에 한 6억
이상 아파트를 산다라고 했을 때이
자금이 어디서 났는지 자금 조달
계획서를 쓰는데 경매를 낙찰받는
경우에는이 자금 조달 계획서까지도 안
써도 됩니다. 게다가 권리 분석만
잘하면 명도에 대한 이슈도 없고이
소유권 이전이 오히려 더 깨끗하게
이전받을 수가 있습니다. 단점 같은
경우에는 이게 아무래도 공시돼 있다
보니까 경쟁자들이 되게 많아질 수
있습니다. 밉지가 좋은 부동산 같은
경우에는 경쟁이 되게 심해요. 그래서
낙찰받기가 실질적으로 좀 어렵습니다.
많이 이제 좀 생각하는게 아, 경매는
무조건 싸게 살 수 있구나. 그런
인식들이 되게 많긴 하는데 요즘 같은
경우에는 감정가보다 그 이상으로
낙찰되는 경우도 되게 많습니다. 경매
내에서도 양극화가 되게 심해지고
있다라고 좀 알고 계시면 될 거 같고
그래서 경매로 이렇게 유찰이 많이
되는 그런 부동산을 관심 있게 보시는
분들이 있는데 저는 일단은 싸다고 다
좋은게 아니에요. 그래서 요즘 같은
때에는 더 양극하가 심해지고 싸다고
잘못 받았다가 나중에 매각하기도 되게
어려워집니다. 지금 같은 시장의
경매에 접근하실 때 무조건 좋은
입지에 있는 부동산만 있으면
들어가겠다라는 생각으로 좀 접근하셔야
되고 그리고 시세보다는 싸게 사기는
쉽지 않아요. 그런 부동산들은 조금
싸게 사면 좋은 거고 그래서 약간
그런 시각으로 좀 접근하시는게 좋은
거 같고 그리고 앞서 설명드렸던
것처럼 토지 거래 허가에 대한 이슈
그런게 없기 때문에 저는 경매로
여러분들이 좀 부동산을 보시는 것도
좋은 방법 중에 하나라고 저는 생각을
합니다. 그리고 이번에 나왔던 악구정
현대 같은 경우에는이 토지 거래
허가를 받지 않아도 되기 때문에
아무래도 입찰자분들이 좀 많이 있었고
이게 처음에 감정가가 72억 원에
나왔어요. 네. 72억 원에 나왔는데
무려 93억 6천에 낙찰이 됐습니다.
그래서 입찰자는 총 일곱명 정도 됐고
지금 이순위 차순위보다 한 3천만 원
더 높게 낙찰이 됐어요. 그리고 이런
재건축 아파트 같은 경우에는 제일
중요한게 조합원 승계입니다. 조합원
승계가 안 되는 아파트를 낙찰받아서
낭패병도 많거든요. 그래서 최근에
여러분들이 기사를 보셨는지 모르겠는데
그 재건축 아파트를 경매로
낙찰받았는데 조합원 승계가 안 되는
거예요. 그래서 현금 청산 당할
위기에 놓였다라는 기사가 나간 적이
있거든요. 잘 모르고 경매 진입을
했다가 그렇게 현금 청산당하는 경우가
종종 있습니다. 근데 지금이 악구정
현대 아파트 같은 경우에는 현금 청산
대상이 아니에요. 그 기사 같은
경우에는 말소 기준 권리가 그 개인
채무 그러니까 이제 아마 사체를
끌어다 쓰신 거 같아요. 그래서 그
기준으로 되었기 때문에 조합원 승계가
안 됐는데 지금이 앞구정 현대 같은
경우에는 그 1 금융권 말소 기준
걸리다 보니까 조합원 승계를 안전하게
받을 수 있습니다.이 재건축 아파트
같은 경우에는 조합원 승계가 되는지가
가장 큰 이슈거든요. 그리고
여러분들이이 경매물을 보실 때 가장
먼저 체크해야 될게 뭐 기본적으로 뭐
입지나 이런 건 당연히 확인을 해야
되고 일단 감정가를 확인을 해야
돼요. 감정 시점이 언젠지. 근데
지금 앞구정 현대가 매우 핫하거든요.
진짜 매 월 다른 거 같아요. 아니
매 주마다 다른 거 같아요. 워낙
매물도 없다 보니까. 그리고
여러분들이 또 확인하셔야 될게 지금
조합원 이런 사무실이 있거든요. 조합
사무실. 어, 여기 가서도 크로스
체크를 했습니다. 그래서 안전히 승계
받을 수 있다라는 걸 체크를 했었고
그리고 지금 유치권 신고가 되어
있었어요. 그래서 유치권이 뭐냐면
지금 이거 같은 경우에는 그 건설사의
유치권이 설정이 돼 있었어요. 그래서
한 8억 정도 설정이 되어 있었는데
근데 저희가 실제로 가서 보니까
유치권자가 점유를 하지 않고 있었고
그리고 보통 유치권 현장 보면은
이렇게 막 큰 플랭카드 있잖아요.
근데 그런 것도 없었습니다. 그래서
유치권 성립 요소가 되지 않았어요.
거기 송달 내역에 보니까 유치권 취소
신고서가 올라와 있더라고요. 그래서
여러분들이 보실 때 만약에이 유치권이
그냥 설정되어 있다고 그냥 검토를
아예 안 할게 아니라 이렇게 직접
가서이 유치권이 진짜 유치권이
맞는지까지도 체크를 해 봐야 됩니다.
근데 지금이 악구정 현대 같은
경우에는 유치권 신고가 최초에 되어
있긴 했지만 전혀 문제 없는 어 그런
매물이었어요. 그리고 이제 또 현장
가서 또 확인해야 될게 관리 사무소의
관리 민합한게 있는지 없는지도 확인을
해야 돼요. 이거 같은 경우에는 직접
가서 확인하니까 뭐 민남 내용은 따로
없다라고 합니다. 좀 정리를 해
보자면 우선 재건축 조합원 승계가
되는지가 가장 컸어요. 근데 이게
정상적으로 승계가 된다라는 거를 첫
번째로 확인을 했었고 그리고 기존에
유치권 신고가 되어 있었는데 이게
성립 요건이 안 된다라는 것까지도
확인을 했었습니다. 기타 부수적으로
뭐 관리비라든지 이런 거 이슈가
없는지도 확인을 했고 인근에 있는
부동산들도가 가지고 좀 체크를 해
봐야 돼요. 네. 그래서 이런
종합적인 부분이 좀 필요하긴 합니다.
처음 하시는 분들은 이런 거 하기가
좀 쉽진 않으실 거예요. 그리고 진짜
경매 업체 중에 이상한데 진짜
많거든요. 지방에 어떤 이상한
빌라사라고 계속 권유하는 경우도 되게
많고 투자 가치가 없는 거를 그냥
소액으로 살 수 있다라고 하는데도
되게 많고 그리고 지금 더 사자는
뭐냐면 예를 들어서 뭐 1억짜리예요.
그러면 뭐 1억 5천에 쓰라 그래요.
그리고 이순위도 같이 들어가는 거.
그니까 어쨌든 가격 차이가 많이 나면
안 되잖아요. 지금 1억짜리인데 1억
5천을 쓴 거잖네요. 일단은 낙찰를
받아야 본인이 돈을 받으니까 갑자기
이순이랑 가격 차이가 막 몇 천 나면
안 되잖아요. 그래서 1억 4천 막
얼마 쓰는 업체들도 있으이 진짜
사자예요. 그런데도 은근 많거든요.
그래서 그런데 조심해야 됩니다.
그래서 정리를 해 보면 막 싸다고
무슨 지방에 이상한 거 사면 진짜
큰일 납니다. 그리고 업체 잘못
만나면 극적으로 막 낙찰된 것처럼 어
포장하는 데가 너무 많아요. 그래서
이런 업체 조심하셔야 됩니다. 그래서
저희가 이번에 경매 팀을
만들었습니다. 직접 대리해서 어 매수
신청도 해 드릴 수 있을 것 같고
앞으로 이제 경매팀을 꾸려서 할
예정인데 경매팀에서는 보고서를 좀
만들어 드려요. 그래서 여기 보면은
예상
낙찰가에까지도 해 드립니다. 그래서
뭐 입지 분석뿐만 아니라 권리 분석
뭐 이런 이슈 상황들 뭐 이거 악구정
현대 같은 경우에는 조합은 승계라든지
그런 판례 같은 것도 좀 여기 같이
담아 드리고 관리비 민압 내역 뭐
토지 거래 허가 뭐 기타 내용들까지도
다
상세하게어요 보고서에 좀 담아 드리고
그니까 인근의 이제 매각 사례라든지
그 최근에 이제 뭐 경매 낙찰된
비율이라든지 진짜 얼추 비슷하게
나옵니다. 그래서 저희가 이게
데이터가 조금 쌓이기 시작했어요.
그리고 자체적으로 건축사 사무소라든지
시공사가 있어서 나중에 뭐 리모델링
했을 때 그런 건축적인 부분이라든지
건설 비용까지도 미리 체크가 가능하게
보고서를 만들 수 있습니다.이 만약에
내가 경매에 한번 이런 물건 리스트
같은 걸 한번 받아보고 싶다라고
하시는 분 계시면 제가 이메일 주소
남겨 드릴테니까 여기 성함이랑 이메일
주소 같이 보내 주시면 어 그리고
규모 정도도 좀 보내 주시면 좋을 거
같아요. 좀 세부적으로 해 가지고
보내 주시면 정말 괜찮은 경매 매물이
나왔을 때 저희가 그 리스트들을 좀
보내 드리겠습니다. 상세하게 한번
상담을 받아보고 싶다라고 하시면은
어느 정도 수고비 정도만 받고 이런
보고서 같은 것도 만들어 드리니까
관심 있으신 분들은 어 이메일 보내
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 경매에도
무조건 잘 살 수 있거나 그렇진
않아요. 여기서도 잘 선별을 해야
되고 분석을 잘해야지 어 괜찮은 거를
낙차받을 수 있지. 무조건 뭐 가격이
싸다고 잘못 들어갔다가 정말 큰일
납니다. 그래서이 경매 쪽에서도 내가
만약에 좀 관심 있다라고 하시면은
연락 주시면 저희 빌사남이
도와드리도록 하겠습니다. 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하겠습니다. 습니다.